foreign
let's go to Nick in
hold on before we go to Nick this is
like a whole look at this man we got
millions of people out here in the in
the home audience there's not really
Millions but it's fun to say that all
right let's go to Nick in Orlando what's
up Nick
hey man hey uh just enjoying life how
are you I'm I'm giving that a shot too
man I'm working on it life good yeah and
Life's good uh it was great until you
said millions of listeners and then my
heart dropped
hey don't worry man there's like 17 no I
think we're up to like 26 if I'm being
honest there's 26 listeners I'm good
with 26. that's fine yeah actually I
think it is in the millions Brothers
you're here dude so let's do it yeah
might as well
um ultimately
um my wife's body isn't what it used to
be and I want to talk to somebody about
it
foreign
all the millions of people listening I
would like to just say it's been fun
having the show and um
I know that that's intentionally
insensitive this this will be the final
episode okay so tell me uh tell me
what's going on how long you been
married so we've been married uh 10
years uh we were uh we were an athletic
couple dating in in our early marriage
and just adding kids and jobs uh that's
just taking the back seat and so
um I want to I want your advice on
having an open conversation I know it's
obvious
um I know my wife's confidence has taken
a toll
um so I want to
I just want to help if I can and hear
your thoughts on it how have you tried
to help already
um we early on we tried a workout
program together
um I wasn't telling her certainly to go
lose weight we took a team effort and I
feel like I I held up my end of the
bargain and I felt like she dropped the
ball and just wasn't motivated enough
and I wasn't
I I wasn't going to be the jerk to keep
her accountable and that wasn't my role
and so you were just a jerk that was
gonna walk around with a wife that you
thought was a lazy bum and no
anyway
um I mean
so so
I'll start the whole conversation this
way you are allowed uh you're allowed to
do whatever you want to
um I don't have one ounce and I I've got
no problem with
um
you being attracted to who and what
you're attracted to that's that's up to
you okay not gonna get any judgment from
me like there's no drinking the haterade
on that one okay
um the challenge here is the way you're
framing this
feels like
whether you meant to or not you you had
conditions on a non-conditional on an
unconditional love relationship
and you found them and this sounds like
yes there's attraction issues but it
sounds like
I don't know many married couples who
haven't experienced this and
the maybe the like the image attraction
changes but the total love in the
household the the connectivity all that
stuff doesn't change sure and so
when you say things like she dropped the
ball she screwed up now you're getting
into character issues and my my bigger
concern is
that what what you are going to point
your fingers at is this is an attraction
issue this is a like she's put on 40
pounds or 50 pounds and I don't think
she's pretty anymore she used to be a
hot athlete and now she's not
is
is cover for it's real it's true you're
less attracted to her but it's cover for
I think my wife is lazy I think she I
think she baited and switched me and
she's ripping me off I got you I think
I'm embarrassed when she wears certain
things out in public because I have an
image that I want to does that make you
see what I'm saying tell me if I'm I'm
off or if I like and here we're already
in it so just be honest
tell me where you are there
no they that all Rings true
um I I I I don't think that she's lazy
and I think that she wishes she had more
time
and more effort or more self-motivation
um to work out and to take care of
things
um
I
yeah I'm still processing I guess
um
I think that
ultimately I don't think that I've set
that condition
um
that you stated but I don't think
let me say it this way most people
unless you're a a like just a truly evil
person you're a psychopath or you're
just like a lame like loser
very few people look at
their their just for this example it
their wife in this example and say
you've gained too much weight you
disgust me
I'm not like I I'm grossed out by you
like that that level of vitriol is is
rare that's rare but it's not common
sure what's way way more common
is your wife knows you don't think she's
pretty anymore
I got you you don't cut glances at her
anymore you don't give her hugs anymore
you keep the lights off he and so it
creates an air that y'all are sharing
you're both breathing this where she
might not be able to put her finger on
it but she knows
you're out
gotcha and it's very very hard to like
um
you can only be who you want to be when
you've got us a group of people
supporting you walking alongside you
that you know have your back and only
then can you repel off the side and go
do great and wonderful and crazy things
and that can be as little as
hate I'm I'm clearing the deck for you
an hour a day and not followed up with
so you can get some gym time in
it's I'm gonna clear an hour a day
because I see how hard you're working
and I love you more than life itself
and I Mike for the next 60 days I'm
gonna give you an hour of your life back
I'm gonna do all of bedtime I'm gonna do
all the dishes I'm gonna come home with
dinner
and you're thinking I'm super busy I
work full time she
that's what support and context feels
like yeah not hey we need to get a
workout program together because she
knows right she she knows you don't like
her but she knows you don't think you're
she's beautiful right that makes sense
yeah and you don't think she's beautiful
on both like both physically and
she's just not she used to be doing this
but she's just not cutting it anymore
and I know that sounds so harsh to hear
that out loud but that's where we are
right right
um
so is there are there any I guess I'm
looking for practical and sensitive ways
to even talk about it is there anything
to talk about
um or is this just a simply a lead by
example and just keep an open coyote we
keep an open conversation with our kids
about good and bad things to eat and
taking care of our bodies we've we've
established that is there anything more
I can do besides just opening time up
through the day and and I can I can
practice that I can do that
um is there is there anything else I can
add to that I think you need to do some
really deep soul searching
about
um
whether you're in this marriage or not I
gotcha and
I can't tell you man more times than not
do you do you have somebody else no I
don't is there somebody that you work
with that makes you smile and laugh a
little bit more or is it pretty hot
nope um I'm not there's not a specific
woman there is a there's a I'm honestly
I'm jealous of the dads or husbands that
have the fit wives
um because I see their motivation or
maybe even like obsessity
um to a fault Obsession of obsessity is
a new word yeah uh congratulations
thanks
um um you can just to a fault and I I
don't want to swing that pendulum too
far to where it's on in an unhealthy
habit
um just looking to to improve all of us
I think you need to be very honest with
your wife
okay and I think the conversation is
about you not her
okay
and I think the conversation begins with
I
am struggling with physical attraction
I'm struggling with the fact that I've
created a house where you're so
exhausted and you're so fried and you're
so out of gas
um that you've got no space and that's
on me
and I'm sorry that like this is not the
moment you go to and you've let yourself
go and you're doing these things then by
God she's got to defend herself oh yeah
yeah but checking out of the
conversation and I guarantee you you've
got your issues
right yeah
um
if I'm super honest dude there's
something you're not telling me what's
the what's a bigger what's there's
something underneath this and here's why
like I said every couple every couple on
earth goes through weight Transitions
and fluctuations and you have kids and
all hormones change every and get busy
at work I've put on weight
I've worked with with guy like during
the book writing process my eating has
gotten bananas and so I use it as a
lifting face but I've put on some weight
okay I just have it's a fluctuation and
so that's normal that's a part of you
can see it if you go look on the
thumbnails of my shows you can see I've
put weight on my face like I've just
gained weight
um and I'll go through another phase
whenever I'm done and I'm back so
there's an ebb and flow to all
relationships there's something
underneath this what is it man
I I don't know that there is
um
so your wife is perfect in every way and
you love your life you love your sex
life you love your intimacy life you
love laughing and playing it's just she
just isn't pretty anymore
that's what I'm aware of I don't know of
something underlying and there could be
I just I don't have that answer for you
um I'll I'll do that soul searching to
find out but I just don't know okay
um
I think you need a season of repentance
for for with her for one big reason
she has gotten the message loud and
clear you don't like her you don't
approve of her and that's got to stop
either either that or you gotta leave
man because you're being cruel
no and uh yeah and it's all unspoken I'm
I'm
I know that she senses that I know that
she's unhappy with with where she's at
too and and so I agree with you
um how
how practically can I open that
conversation up without offending her
dude
you're offending her by
your whole your whole life with her is
an offense and so I would say that ship
has already sailed there's going to be
tears in this conversation there's going
to be frustration there's going to she's
gonna be pissed off at you like all
that's going to happen so you can't
avoid that what you can do is speak
about you
about what you're willing to do to
create a world where she feels safe and
feels loved and feels like her her
relationship with you isn't contingent
on
um caloric intake and only then can she
say I want to make some changes too
like my buddy Sal the Stefano's like you
can't hate your body into long-term
change right and you can't hate your
wife into studying harder or you can't
hate your wife or be grossed out by your
wife until she gets in better shape
that's a recipe for a nuclear explosion
understood okay and so do you see what
I'm saying like this this conversation
is about you yes it's gonna be you're
gonna have to be honest
I'm I strong I'm struggling with with
the traction here I'm also struggling
with the fact that I've created a world
where you don't feel safe anymore
you know also you're gonna have to make
peace if she says I think I'm beautiful
yeah and this is how I am and this is
who I roll yes I used to be a runner or
a karate champion or whatever that's not
my world anymore I got two little kids
now this is my world and then you are
gonna have to look at her in the eye and
say I love you to the moon and back or
you gotta go right
right because you got you also got two
little ones that you're teaching hey by
the way this is what love looks like
and love looks like silence or love
looks like
or love looks like are you sure you
wanna have another bowl of ice cream
honey or why didn't you work out today
that's that's they're picking all that
up man they're picking up all of it all
of it all of it all of it all of it
and as somebody who spent a lot of my
life walking alongside people with
disordered eating challenges man it's
just a wrestle it's just man it's just a
mess
you have to own the person you fell in
love with
and that you looked in the eye and said
I'll be with you forever no matter what
and attraction comes and goes feelings
come and go that's part of it
but you're gonna have to decide whether
you love this woman or not and you're
gonna have to plug in there all other
healing and weight loss and all that
other stuff comes after
I'm not going anywhere and I will love
you for now and forever
um
that's the only platform long-term
healing
can can be anchored into